also in Washington DC's Lamar Lamar how
are you I'm good how are you doing
better than I deserve what's up man kind
of question my fiance is still on the
mortgage loan with her ex-husband Oh
Lord yeah and it wasn't specified a
divorce decree as to when to sell it so
I was trying to figure out what her
options to get out of it or are there
any huh the mortgage company is not
going to let her go the only way that
that she gets like I was when that alone
is paid off it's only paid off when he
sells the house or refinances the house
what is the interest rate I'm not even
aware of that okay
what is the the relationship how toxic
is it with her ex not very so fairly
amiable okay do you have any idea what
the loan amount is no okay what do you
guys make a year um me 130 her about the
same okay you're making Bank good for
you guys what do you all do for a living
telecommunications good for you Dee very
cool well thank you good okay
sorry here's where I'm here's what I'm
fishing because I wanted to gather piece
of information or two to see if it would
work it once you guys are out of debt
not counting this house that she still
has her name on what she's still in debt
on once you guys are out of debt and you
have your emergency fund in place is
that where you are today are you working
your way out working my way okay when I
won one last credit card to pay off okay
get that paid off build your emergency
fund and this is what in business we
might call a contingent liability you
know it's not a liability and he'll he
doesn't pay the bill and then it screws
her over right and if he ever doesn't
pay the bill so what I would do is begin
to gather up little information now on
this loan and here might be a strategy
let's pretend
that we are in a three and a half
percent market which we are today for
mortgage rates and let's pretend he's
sitting on a five percent loan well
beforehand rates are kind of ticking up
a little bit right now let's you know so
it would be to his advantage to
refinance and get a better interest rate
right which would also set her free by
the way so if he has enough loan - if he
has enough room he doesn't owe so much
on the loan they don't know so much on
the loan versus the value of the house
the loan-to-value ratio and you guys got
plenty of money you're making Bank and
you you know what I would do is approach
him and go you know dude her let her
approach him or whatever however is the
best way to beacon persuasive and just
say you know you got a 5% loan here I'm
using this as an example you could get a
three and a half and when you did that
it would let me go if you would do that
I would pay a couple thousand dollars of
your closing costs and if I were you two
I'd be willing to pay a couple thousand
dollars to get off that loan and to spur
him on to do something that otherwise he
might not be spurred on to do you know
what I'm saying mm-hmm it's worth a
couple grand to me to not be on that
loan in case he goes sideways at some
point okay and so just try to you know
negotiate work with him and just go if
you would refinance it we don't have any
you don't have an obligation to do that
but it would be to your advantage
because you get a better interest rate
once you find out the interest rate and
if you can qualify for it and all that
and get it get me off the loan then you
know I talked to my husband and you know
we'd pay a couple thousand dollars of it
if you go ahead and get it done just
because we won't rid of the risk and
then there's no nothing in the divorce
to create a for sure to do it sooner
so I'm negotiating with you to try to
get you to do it now I'm not gonna pay
ten thousand dollars you know what I'm
saying but I'm just the only thing it's
just in the back of my mind worrying
that this guy's some point goes sideways
loses a job or gets a drinking problem
or whatever happens with ex-husbands
right and all the sudden doesn't pay the
bill well you know your wife is gonna be
foreclosed on your wife's credit is
going
destroyed every time he doesn't pay the
bill on time and so it's worth it to me
to get rid of that risk to a couple
grand again I'm not gonna spend a
bazillion dollars on this but if it's
amiable and you can have you know like
civil discussions about this with the
guy you or her then that would be the
idea and then be the direction to go so
good question man thanks for listening
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]